so women who date those types of guys
can they expect that type of successful
multi-millionaire whether he's a
professional basketball player a
professional medical doctor
to stay faithful
i don't know if you can from though that
that has always been the issue and the
challenge with me is because number one
when you are performing at such a high
rate in terms of what you do to acquire
money uh your mind needs a bit of
fantasy to relax
am i okay with that not for where i am
in my life like where i'm not i
understand it and i and i can see how
you know this is how you need to
distress and how you like to entertain
yourself and sometimes how monogamy can
really feel like monotony to you and i
understand these things but in terms of
like i i also my boys i have two boys
they're nine and eleven so it's very
very important that i one do not degrade
what it means to create a family just
because you're an economic provider you
understand i cannot um undermine what
their father is in terms of you know how
they contributed their lives in terms of
manhood just because you are
economically you know stable that's just
one part of it and i think women who
preach hyper gaming and all of that
they're not really looking into you know
who this man is and what he has to do to
relax you understand i don't think
people who who go after you know they
say i'm into hypergamy they don't
consider what this person who makes that
amount of money the amount of
intelligence they have the amount of
genius they have how hard they work and
if they decide they're only going to
focus on you it really requires an
intense amount of focus because
literally there's women you know
throwing themselves at them in abundance
in abundance and that and the doctor the
lawyer even just an attractive man who
makes six figures let's talk about this
attractive man over here this guy uh i
mean look
nick sarnicola nix arnicola google this
guy this guy was making a ton of money
in your business hundreds of thousands
of dollars per month fair to say oh yeah
how the [ __ ] did you stay faithful or
did you not i didn't you didn't
okay walk us through that
by the way you're from michigan you
moved to miami yeah first of all you're
an outstanding human being like just
very eloquent very eloquent
uh well i moved to california i was 20.
okay um and on the journey of the
industry i was in it was just all about
leadership so i went on a 10-year
accidental case study of leadership
and first was like how-to's and then it
became this
this person on leadership jfk on
leadership linking on leadership uh and
then it became reading the biographies
of world-changing leaders past and
present
and unfortunately the the more i learned
and
about history and the more i learned
about
present-day leadership
there was a lot of
there was a few things that were in
common with all of them
and that was their lack of monogamy and
i don't know whether that is
whether that's dna or whether that's
what's happening hormonally because of
as she just referenced just the [ __ ]
drive and i don't know what the genghis
khan factor is i don't know what i don't
know what dr i don't know what causes it
i'm not a scientist i i think most
people don't account for the fact that
sexual energy is creative energy it is
creative so the more creative you are
the more sexual you are so when you are
asking a man to harness that amount of
creative energy and he actually gets
compensated for how creative he actually
is it can't be undermined so when you
get a man in in a family situation
because what he's doing outside of that
that is what the
and then i have some arguments that
men
wealthy men wherever however we define
wealth here
they really have to love a woman versus
a woman she has to care for you she has
to be there for you but she's probably
not getting sexual you know things
thrown at her you know on her just all
the time it's not in an abundance so the
husband or from other guys no just from
women like i mean maybe maybe four or
five guys may hit on me whatever in a
week or slide into my dna i feel like
it's the exact opposite way it's the
opposite too i'm like yeah you say it's
obvious i feel like women get
oh they do it if you take an attractive
woman and you take an attractive man and
you put them out in the world i mean and
you have them interact bar setting
whatever it may be
same caliber of income i guarantee you
that woman's gonna have more dms that
woman's gonna have more because guys are
trained hopefully when they're young to
to approach women like you know if you
wanna if you wanna make something happen
you gotta make it happen women are often
told to sit back and they're told oh let
the guy come and do it let the guy
introduce that let the guy so because of
that just by nature of that training
you're going to be
inclined to approach women more so i
mean i mean i worked in media like
listen i my head was exploding a little
bit on this cheating stuff adam you know
that but
i worked in new orleans
well because cheating is a decision it's
not you know it's a decision that you
make like i was hearing um what you were
saying i appreciate it i disagree in
many respects i worked in media for a
very long time you know i hosted at fox
i posted the view i had many men
in very wealthy positions with a lot of
prestige with big microphones all
calibers
come to me actors musicians executives
on-air hosts
and even when i had met jeremy it's
really funny because i had met him and
he's a very regular he's a smart guy he
went to rice university he's very
capable he's a hard worker he was young
first young guy ever dated by the way
the first boyfriend i ever had was 13
years older than me i always went older
he's the exception
and i remember even one day sitting on a
panel with luke perry who was my
childhood heartthrob i was like
and he surprised me on my birthday he
came to the show and i was like jeremy
and i just started going out and i
i just looked at him in the audience and
i was like you know what like i'm really
just not even into this like i don't
i think it really depends on who you are
what stage of life you're at and how you
were raised like i was raised that
you wait unt you don't get married to
just anybody you wait and you find that
person that you're you're just kind of
turned your world around and if you're
gonna cheat
if you're inclined to cheat there's
something wrong in that marriage end it
end it like a relationship going so
you're saying that you shouldn't end the
marriage
i'm saying that if you are inclined to
cheat right if you're saying okay in
order for me to stay in this marriage i
need to cheat if that's your
justification you need to go you need to
figure out what's wrong in that marriage
you need to work at that marriage
particularly if you have children
involved you need to try your best to
fix that if then you decide you can't
don't go cheat on that partner separate
it's not gonna work don't be
disrespectful unless your partner
doesn't care and says hey i don't care
if you sleep around or you've got some
type of situation going on like that
cheating is never going to end well it's
just you're not going to feel good about
it your partner's not going to feel good
about it
if a woman cheats it it takes a lot more
for a woman to cheat a woman has to have
a major emotional investment to cheat a
guy will just go bang a girl because
he's got she's got a big booty or like i
hate to tell you i hate to tell you
there's a lot of girls i don't know like
what's going on in miami there's a lot
of girls in new york city that cheat
that that have that energy you're
talking about and they cheat and it's
physical and they're not madly you're
saying that it's 100 physical physical
they're bored they're more masculine
they're bored yeah that that's they're
not having sex at home with their
husbands they're bored they love their
families they're not looking for a whole
new life but they want to feel good
women have sexual energy too they want
full yeah they want to be all of us have
sexual energy and yeah women want that
they're going for that and they're not
going to look for to see whether you're
calling them the next day the stereotype
is that the woman falls badly in love
with somebody else and they're it's all
about emotion and they're they're
cheating because they're all no
sometimes it's not there are women out
there that it is physical they need that
satisfaction and they don't want to
leave their husbands and if their
husband finds out
yeah what happens next well if he's got
any integrity then he should say i'm out
i'm out i'm done i would never tolerate
cheating that's one thing and i when i
got married i went into it saying listen
i there's a lot of ups and downs we're
going to have there's a lot of things
that are going to go on we're going to
have probably going to have a kid it's
going to be hard
cheating i'm done
that's not for me i'm done so he knew
that but you got it you got it you got
it you got to explain that
and listen no hatred for you that would
have that happened no disrespect i don't
know your situation everybody's got
their own situation of course everybody
and and he was the first to chime in and
say it doesn't end well well explain
your situation except well um
there's so many paths that that you just
went down um first of all has anyone
read mating in captivity by esther
perrell she's the leading authority and
sex therapist couples therapist in the
world nice i strongly sounds like you
were assigned that book no i found it no
no i haven't found it
wow and she she explains both sides
really eloquently so i recommend anybody
read it single married divorce
um in any case um
you reference a lot of ideology right
you reference like well if they're
raised well well my parents are still
married 45 years later my grandparents
were married i was raised really [ __ ]
well yeah um but is it possible that i
was raised well but i'm not monogamous
is it possible i didn't understand those
non-monogamous until years into america
until i'm already now doing things that
go wait am i doing this because i'm not
in love no i'm [ __ ] madly in love
like insanely in love am i doing this
because i don't have money or power no
i've got a lot of it am i doing this
because it's not i don't have enough
attention no i got it so it so i'm still
in this discovery phase so what have you
so
just because i appreciate you sharing
with us
you loved your wife oh i still do she's
amazing okay
you have two beautiful kids together you
were making a ton of money yep you
enjoyed your life yep there's nothing on
paper that says that you should be
cheating by the way i just like your
wife was gorgeous too like just add that
on top of that so what was like all
right i'm in miami is it just so many
options and flavors out there that or
what was it because it must have been
something
to make you say because
there's a difference between looking and
touching so what was like and then once
you did it the first time you got away
with it you're like all right let's
let's roll the next go for time number
two so number one nothing to do with
miami in fact we lived in miami so i was
always on my best behavior in miami
right so it's like
nothing to do with miami um
so it was when you're on the road it's
it's when you know
you and you know that's uh here's how i
relate it if you think you're a
non-monogamous person it's kind of like
maybe you think you're gay and you're
like i don't really know i don't know
how to say this i don't want to
communicate it i don't know how to
but it's how do you know how do you know
if you don't try right so it's like
it's almost like you're in a this like
closet right how do i say this people
are going to judge me people are going
to and then you start experiencing like
[ __ ] okay i don't i think this is the
case now what uh yeah i grenade my
marriage my company my children my how
do i approach this how do you what's
next right and just to be clear you
thought that you're like i don't believe
in monogamy but you found that out after
you were married with kids and all the
success well i would say that the seed
was already there okay um
and and i was
so extremely behaved i didn't date in my
20s all i did was work hundred dollars a
week i [ __ ] just did nothing but
build wealth
and um i was with someone for four years
met my ex-wife right in the middle of it
she was engaged i was four-year
relationship we fell in love we got
married
right so
um
we got we fell in love while we were
both still in our relationships um moved
in together got engaged got married you
know uh and then right into a child it
was bang bang bang bang
it does it doesn't remove that seed of
oh [ __ ] this all just happened so fast
i've never dated so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
[Music]